sziasztok nemrég a vendégem volt
sinzinus szakács pál istván
székelyudvarhely polgármestere és nagyon
sok izgalmas témáról beszélgettünk mint
például az hogy hogyan fogadták őt mint
székely udvarhely újdonsült
polgármestere az elmúlt négy hónapban
körülbelül mi történt de kérdeztem
nehezebb témákról is mint például az
városunknak az adóssága amit nemrég
harangoztak be hogy rengetek pénzt kell
felvegyünk valamint a csapatról is
hamarosan elindul egy belső átvilágítás
és ezzel kapcsolatban is kérdeztem őt
hamarosan jön az epizód viszont hogyha
ezt még nem tetted meg akkor kérlek
iratkozz fel adj egy lájk-ot a videón
vagy pedig írj egy pár kommentet ezek
mind nagyon segítenek nekem abban hogy a
csatornámat fejleszteni tudjam és hogy
bővülni tudjunk úgyhogy tartsatok velünk
a következő epizódban
üdvözlöm a kedves nézőket a vendégem
szakács pál istván szinusz udvarhely
polgármester köszöntelek a stúdiónkban
jó napot kívánok én is köszöntöm a
nézőket és köszönöm ismételten a
meghívást neked szabolcs én én nagyon
örrvendek hogy még egyszer le tudtunk
ülni beszélgetni nagyon kíváncsi vagyok
hogy azóta mi történt ez most számoltuk
ki ez körülbelül olyan hét hónapja volt
amikor leültünk már megnyerted a a
választásokat de még nem voltál
beiktatva mi történt a beiktatásig így
röviden el tudod mondani hogy hogy
zártad le a hbc-s igazgatói múltodat és
és hogy hogyan készültél fel a a
beiktatás ra ühüm hát amikor a kampány
lejárt akkor azért egy hosszabb lélegzet
vételnyi szabadságra mentem el ez három
hetet tartott és azt követően pedig
megpróbáltam normálisan átadni az
inkubátorházat a következő vezetésnek
illetve ott most egy ideig rönes
igazgatóval hamarosan lesz a
versenyvizsga és és egy új vezető lesz
vagy a régi ki udja hogyha ő nyeri meg
ezt a vizsgát de egyébként igyekeztem
egy kicsit már előzetesen megismerni azt
a közeget is ami várni fog rám a
polgármesteri hivatalba úgyhogy
fokozatosan egy-egy olyan
gyűlésre már bejárhattam ami távlatokban
ezt az időszakot fogja érinteni amikor
amikor is én fogom a a város vezetését
ellátni és egy kicsit
képbe igyekeztem tenni magam
közigazgatás szempontjából is tehát
bogaráztam törvényeket néztem azokat a
projekteket amik a rendelkezésünkre
állnak és nyilván ezt amikor nem vagyok
benne hanem kvázi laikusként teszem meg
akkor kaptam egyfajta képet ami
háttérnek egészen biztosan jó volt de a
valóság azért egy kicsit másabb volt
miután megismertem részleteiben a
projekteket tehát így a beiktatás után
érzel egy különbség mi mi mi milyen volt
a beiktatás után mi mi mi várt rád akkor
a beiktatás után készültél a beiktatásig
már tehát egy csomó mindent megismertél
de valami készültem alapstratégiát
állítottam fel hogy hogyan fogok
bemutatkozni a kollégáknak hogy kikkel
fogok gyakrabban beszélni kik lesznek
eset g bizalmi embereim hogyha vannak
ilyenek a a hivatalban igaz egy teljesen
új közegbe kerültem be 150 több mint 150
olyan ember várt rám akit akiket azért
alaposan egyáltalán nem
ismertem voltak egyesekkel kapcsolatban
előítéleim e előítéleteim ezek jó vagy
rossz
előítéletek nyilván fontos volt az hogy
bemutatkozzak mindenkinek erre sort
kerítettünk már az első héten elmondtam
hogy milyen elvek mentén képzelem azt
hogy együtt dolgozunk a következő négy
évben és utána pedig és ezek még most is
zajlanak mert elég sok időt elvesz az
első hónapokban hát most is még csak
négy hónap telt el tehát hogy rengeteg
olyan helyzet van most is hétről hétre
ami újnak számít ami eddig nem fordult
elő ami szezonális és még az a szezon
nem jött el tulajdonképpen úgyhogy elég
sok időt szántam arra hogy egyenként
megismerjem az osztályvezetőket az
igazgatókat és miután bemutat ák a saját
csapatukat lementünk az illető
osztályokra és egyenként beszélgettem
egy keveset a kollégákkal is illetve
elmondtam nekik hogy ha őnekik van
valamilyen olyan jellegű problémájuk
amik úgy érzik hogy kimondottan a
polgármesterre tartoznak akkor jöjjenek
bátran mert nagyon hamar találunk vagy
azonnal találunk nekik időpontot hogy
beszélgetni tudjunk erről az látszik
hogy nagyon nyitottan állsz hozzá a
kommunikációhoz ezeket a kétheti
naplókat folyamatosan nézzük a
feleségemmel de tudom hogy sokan nézik
tehát egyrészt látom a nézettségén is
másrészt az ismerősi körömben most
például a a a fodrásznőmmel beszélgettem
ő nem mulaszt el egyetlen egy
lehetőséget sem hogy megnézze a kétheti
naplódat és és azt látom valamit
elkaptál valamit valamit valamogy
valahogy úgy úgy elkaptad azt a a
ritmust ahogyan ahogyan kommunikálja a
várossal tehát hogy ennek nagyon
őrvendek viszont émeítő rendesen émeítő
hogy mennyi mindent csinálsz így ahogy
gyakorlatilag reggeltől kés ő estig az
az érzetem hogy folyamatosan úton vagy
valamerre valamit csinálsz és emellett
még még még ott van a a városházán
belüli munkád ez tényleg így így
történik te igen emberileg ez egyébként
egy nagy kihívás illetve egy nagy
dilemma most tényleg nagyon sok
időt nagyon sok energiát beleteszek ebbe
a munkába és meggyőződésem hogy most
sokkal többet is kell azért mert most
ismerek meg embereket helyzeteket most
kell megtanulnom azt hogy hogyan
viszonyuljak hogyan kezeljek
bizonyos helyzeteket amik elő fognak
majd fordulni a következő időszakban is
nagyon kevés időm van magamra ez ez
helyenként látszik is
de én is azt látom hogy jól fogadták a
városlakók ezt a fajta nyitottságot
szóval örvendenek annak hogy egy kicsit
részesei tudnak lenni egy
polgármesternek a hétköznapjainak
belelátnak bizonyos ügyekbe adott
esetben belelátnak folyamatokba is
hiszen azért én igyekszem a videók
előre is jelezni olyan dolgokat amikkel
amikkel én akkor szembesülök tehát
hogyha azt látom hogy elveszítünk egy
pert aminek fontos kihatása lesz majd
akár a költségvetésre akár bizonyos
projektekre én arra utalok videókba az
ez meg egy jó dolog azt gondolom hiszen
vissza tudok utalni majd rá akkor hogyha
valóban az fog történni hogy ki kell
fizessük ezt a kárt hogy igen ahogy
jeleztem egy hónappal ezelőtt ez meg ez
bekövetkezett
és valahogy én ezt várnám el egyébként a
politikus társaimtól is úy átrlag
polgárként hogy egy kicsit tavassanak be
abba is hogy ők hogyan hoznak döntéseket
milyen folyamatok vezetnek ehhez milyen
dilemmák elé állította őket az élet
mielőtt mielőtt egyszerűen így a fejünk
fölött meghoznak egy bizonyos döntéseket
no ezek a kétheti naplók erre jók
nyilván egy csomó mindent nem tudok
beletenni hiszen amikor van egy
népszerem közti beszélgetés amikor van
egy olyan gyűlés ah bizonyos projekteket
kibeszélünk kollégákkal akkor nincsen
ott a kamera és ez jól is van így de én
is azt látom hogy eléggé tartalmas már
már hosszú nagyon sokat dolgozik a a
kedves kolléga azon hogy azért rövidre
szapjaan nézhető legyen ez a ez a
formátum megemészthető legyen a a
közönségnek és tényleg én hálásan
köszönöm nagyon jól fogadják egyelőre
nem kopott el a varázsa biztos egy
kicsit később kopni fog mert megszokják
mert egy kicsit láunnak talán az emberek
illetve én is törekszem arra hogy
legyenek más formátumok például a mai
kérdez felelek vagy tegnapi kérdez
felelek az az erről szólt kérdésekre
válaszoltam amik foglalkoztatják a
lakosságot és igyekeztem röviden és
és konkrétan válaszolni ezekre h hol
lehet kérdéseket feltenni kérdéseket
privát üzenetben is fel lehet tenni ezek
erre sokkal fogékonyabbak a városlakók
hiszen vannak olyan kérdések amit nem
szeretnének a nagynyilvánosság előtt fel
de akár kommentben is akár be lehet
jönni a hivatalba a titkárságon hagyni
egy-egy kérdést és ha olyan hogy úgy
gondolom hogy közérdeklődésre is számot
tesz akkor a videóba számolok be a
válaszokkal vagy videókban jelentkezem a
válaszokkal hogyha olyan hogy úgy
gondolom hogy egy szűk rétet vagy szűk
réteget vagy egy konkrét személyt érint
akkor viszont felhívom az illetőt vagy
behívom egy fogadó órára én őszintén
szól nagyon élveztem a legutolsó kétheti
naplódban hogy elmentél sző ilka nénihez
és zsigmond aranka
nénihez és nagyon tényleg tehát én nem
is tudtam róluk és tényleg így ahogy
láttam egy pár féképet vagyis pár videó
snittet nagyon gyönyörű festményeket
készítenek hol találod ezeket a
személyeket ki jaavasolja vagy vagy
kicsit olyan érzésem van mint mátyás
királyal hogy áruhát felveszi és akkor
egyszer csak hirtelen felbukkan
valamelyik néninél kávézni
egyet hol találod ezeket a lehetőségeket
sajnos nem áll ruhába de egyébként ez
egy nagyon jó forgató könyv lenne
bizonyos helyzeteknek a megismeréséhez
és és helyes következtetéseknek a
levonásához hogyha egy egyszer áruhába
is el tudnák jutni bizonyos helyekre
irka néni ő volt már bent a hivatalban
és meghívott hogy hogy egyszer amikor
időm engedi akkor látogassak el a
lakásába ami jegegybe a műterme is
aranka néni ő teljesen más ő ezt
professzionális szinten őzi ő neki egy
nagyon gazdag élettörténet van
gyakorlatilag korszakokra lehet bontani
azt hogy ő mi szerint alkotott volt egy
időszak amikor az egyesült államokban
ért aztán ő onnan hazaköltözött hó
elképesztően gazdag a gyűjteménye
például tényleg zsigmond aranka néninek
a
a termét azt azt bátran merném
turistáknak is ajánlani na hát én nagyon
értékelem személy szerint hogy erre is
van időd és energiád és kíváncsi vagyok
hogy ezt hogy fogod tudni tovább hogy
érzed fáradtnak érzed most magad ez az
elsőé van amikor igen most egy kicsit
csalóka kép mert hogy egy nőnapi hétvége
aztán közeledik a március 15-ös hétvége
úgyhogy most kimondottan fáradt vagyok
de
egyébként élvezem nem tölt el akkora
elégtétellel mint az eddigi munkahelyeim
mertogy egész egyszerűen néha azt érzem
hogy és ezzel szembesítenek nagyon
korrektül a a városlakók is vagy a
kommentelők is hogy kicsit sok a duma és
még keveset látnak és hát nyilván négy
hónap telt el tehát nem tudunk nagyon
sokat megmutatni még de azt gondolom
hogy ha egy év múlva két év múlva három
év múlva a duma mellé a megvalósítások
is felsórakoznak akkor akkor egy jó
időszaka lesz
városunknak abszolút tehát hogy hogy
nyilván négy hónap ilyen szempontból ez
egy nagyon rövid idő de én is kíváncsi
vagyok hogy egyáltalán mit lehet tehát
hogy az az az kétely nincs bennem hogy a
hozzáállásod meg a szándékod abszolút
abszolút konstruktív és a
lehetőlenagyobb tempób szeretnéd
székelyudvarhelynek a hajóját egy kicsit
megfordítani és kíváncsi vagyok hogy
mennyi idő alatt lehet ezt mennyi idő
alatt lehet
látványosan elvégezni most nyilván itt
nem csak rólad van szó mert kell egy
csapat mögéd és ezt a legutóbbi
alkalommal is nagyon hangsúlyoztad hogy
te egy csapatjátékos vagy csapatban
gondolkozol hogy alakul ez a csapat
amúgy hát van egy külső csapat ez az
rmds-nek a csapata akinek a színeiben
megnyertük a választásokat és én azt
gondolom hogy ez egy nagyon sok színű
csapat mindenhol vannak szakembereink
erről már sokat beszéltünk legyen a
sport oktatás
kultúra közösségi ügyek vannak vannak
olyan önkormányzati képviselőink akik az
illető területeket szakértői szinten
ismerik úgyhogy az ő segítségükre
számítható itt éppen az az egyik
legnagyobb kihívás hogy nyilván ők is
azért kerültek be az önkormányzatba mert
valamit tenni akarnak a saját
területükön azt akarják hogy szintet
lépjen a város legyen szó oktatásról
legyen szó kulturális rendezvényekről
városnapokról
egyáltalán a civil szervezetek
támogatásáról sporttámogatásról és nem
tudjuk költségvetésileg tartani a lépést
velük ez ilyen szempontból pozitív hogy
tetrekész proaktív csapat van az
önkormányzati testületben és a
legnagyobb kihívás az pont most a
költségvetés elkészítésének az időszaka
van pont az volt a legnagyobb kihívás
hogy hogyan mínusz65 millió lejről
indultunk tehát annyival kellett a a
tervezett kiadásokat a
bevételeinkhez igazítsuk elképesztő
munka volt és nagyon sok áldozatot
kellett hozzunk ahhoz hogy ma azt arról
tájékoztattak a kollégák hogy végre
szinten van a költségvetés tehát talál a
bevételi és kiadási oldal is hát ide
hiteleket kellett felvegyünk
és ráadásul nem is arra vettük fel a
hiteleket feltétlen amire szerettük
volna szóval van egy tetrekész proaktív
önkormányzati képviselői csapat akik nem
riadnak meg a munkától sem tehát
ők rendszeresen üléseznek a saját
területükön kisebb területekre is
bizottságokat hoztunk létre tehát nem
csak sportbizottságunk van nem csak
kulturális vagy szociális bizottságunk
hanem összeraktunk egy olyan bizottságot
aki például a virágárosoknak a
kérdésével foglalkozik mert ott vannak
problémák és ott is látni fogják majd a
városlakók hogy a következő hónapokban
azért jól látható intézkedések fognak
történni úgyhogy én azt gondolom az
rendben van nem tudjuk pénzzel tartani
velük a lépést de meggyőződésem hogy
máshol ez is ez így szokott lenni és hát
alakul a hivatali a belső apparátus is
ami azért a szűk keresztmset
gyakorlatilag ahhoz hogy a vágyainkból
vagy ha úgy tetszik az ígéreteinkből
amiket a kampány során felvállaltunk
megval ítások legyenek a másik területen
hivatali apparátusnál látni kell azt
hogy ott egyfajta átszerveződésre
készülünk
ott megismerjük a a környezetet
megismerjük egyenként az embereket
hangsúlyosan a vezetőket és utána
március-április hónap folyamán be fogunk
jelenteni egy átszervezést azért hogy
optimalizáljuk a hivatalnak a működését
azt látom hogy vannak emberek akik
kicsit
belefásultak ilyen úgymond nyugdíjas
állásnak tekintik ezt az egészet őket
megpróbáljuk felfrissíteni adott esetben
áthelyezni máshova hátha ott újra
lendületet kapnak vagy újra szárnyakra
kellnek hogyha úgy
tetszik és lesznek olyan osztályok olyan
részlegek amiket teljes egészében újra
kell gondoljunk és a mai modern kor
követelményeinek megfelelően
átalakítsunk de erről folyamatosan
beszélgetünk hát olyan nagyon fontos
vezetői pozíciónk vannak betöltetlenül
amiket hogyha nem tudunk rövid határidőn
belül megoldani akkor még komolyabb
versenyhátrlányba kerülünk a a
környékbeli városokkal szemben melyek
ezek a pozíciók például nincsen
fejlesztés beruházási igazgatónk nincsen
gazdasági igazgatónk nincsen
városmenedzserünk tehát három olyan
vezetői poszt ami szerintem meghatározó
a polgármester alpolgármester főjegyző
mellett kik jelentkezzenek akkor most ez
egy jó lehetőség szakemberek szakemberek
egy kérésünk van olyanok jelentkezzenek
és lesznek ilyen szempontból
állás lesznek ilyen szempontból
lehetőségek akiknek azért van
közigazgatási
tapasztalatuk és és
akik nem félnek meghozni döntéseket
tehát felelősséget mernek vállalni és
annak a tudatában jelentkezzenek hogy
valóban felelősségteljes a munka tehát
millió lejekről kell dönteni és egy-egy
forgatókönyvnek vagy egy-egy döntésnek a
meghozatala az valóban nagyon sok
mindenkire kihatással van a városlakókra
kivitelezőkre egyáltalán a célcsoportra
ahol az illető beavatkozások történnek
szóval mindenképpen szakembereket várunk
és vezetői pozícióba elsősorban üüm és
hát ezek az aktuálisan üresállások lehet
hogy lesznek még hüm tehát ez a három
pozíció az ami ez a három amit így
hirtelen kapásból
el tudtam s van vannak azért jelentkez
ötletek a háttérben hogy kikkel tölts be
nem mondanám hogy nem zajlik egy
háttérmunka ahol megpróbálunk
beazonosítani olyan személyeket akik a
saját területükön kiemelkedő
tapasztalattal és tudással bírnak és egy
ilyen fontos pozíciót mint még egyszer
mondom a fejlesztésberuházási igazgató
az az egyik legfontosabb pozíció
euromilliók sorsáról dönt az ő
proaktivitása vagy éppen passzivitása
azt azt eredményezi hogy elindulunk új
pár ázati kiírásokon vagy éppen nem
indulunk el és lemaradunk róla de a
gazdasági igazgató is az is egy hasonló
pozíció vagy éppen a a városmenedzser
aki az egész hivatali apparátust tudja
vezetni tehát hogy mindenre kell legyen
egy kicsi rálátása és ő sem kell vagy ő
sem lenne szabad féjen attól hogy
döntéseket hozzon bizonyos
esetekben beszélgetünk emberekkel
beszélgettünk emberekkel sokan jelezték
hogy ők szívesen megpróbálnak és azt
mondtuk hogy talán ez a feladat nem
nekik való vagy nem igazából mi itt most
a
a egy fontos kritérium hogy én látom az
alpolgármester úron is és látom illetve
tudom magamról is hogy nagyon sok munkát
beleteszünk ebbe tehát nem napi nyolc
órázunk és azt szeretnénk hogyha vezető
beosztásba lévő emberek úgy jönnének
hogy ezt tudomásul vennék tehát
megértenék azt hogy ne ez nem egy nyolc
órás munka ez 10-12 és lehet hogy
hétvégén is hívni fogjuk őket ühüm és ez
ez így lesz két év múlva is szerinted
mikor remélem hogy nem tehát hogy nekem
egy konkrét ígéretem volt a kollégákhoz
hogy nem fog kelleni túlórázzanak most
sem kell
de hogyha elvárjuk azt a jó indulatot
tőlük hogyha látják ők is azt hogy egy
projektnek az a gátja hogy ők éppen azon
a héten napi egy vagy két órával többet
bennülnek n m kelljen mondjuk ők
maguktól lássá hogy igen hogyha én most
10 órát dolgozom a héten akkor ezt a
projektet le tudjuk adni jó eséllyel meg
fogjuk nyerni és meg is fogjuk tudni
valósítani nekünk is nagyon fontos ez az
egy-két év annyira
lassú sajnos romániában a a közsfére
annyira lassan kapunk különféle
engedélyeket meg hogy most mondjak egy
példát hogyha ebben az évben nem döntjük
el hogy a városnak mely
utcáiban szeretnénk azt hogy a kábelek a
földből bekerüljenek a a a kábelek a
levegőből bekerüljenek a föld alá akkor
ezt nem tudjuk megoldani 2028-ig tehát
csak amíg egy tervezés és egy
az elektrikával párhuzamosan egy
engedélyeztetés megtörténik az kettő év
utána pedig ki kell írni a közbeszerzést
a kivitelezésre és meg kell valósítani
tehát ha idén valamelyik utcáról nem dől
el hogy a kábelek a föld alá kerülnek
akkor az már egy második mandátumra vagy
egy következő mandátumra marad ha úgy
tetszik h egy kicsit mesélnél-e nekünk
erről a a a mondtad hogy a költségvetési
hiány 65 millió lej volt ami nem a
költségvetési hiány hanem amikor
mindenkinek betettük
a az álmát
gyakorlatilag akkor volt egy 65 millió
lees mínuszunk értem értem értem az ez
az tényleg más viszont most olvastam
nemrég az uh-ban hogy fel kell vegyünk
kölcsönt sőt már felvettünk
5,65 millió lejes hitelt és még egy
20-30 millió lejre szükség les
emlékszem amikor a a kampány alatt ezt a
kérdést boncolgattuk hogy mennyi is az
annyi tehát hogy mivel én közelebbről
láttam így a a feleségem önkormányzati
képviselő volt és közelebbről láttam úgy
láttuk hogy itt itt azért tetemes
mennyiségű hitelre lesz szükség viszont
valahogy úgy aztán elkezdtünk nem
beszélni róla én sem értem pontosan egy
ilyen homály fedi körbe az egészet és
emlékszem hogy hogy galfi azt is mondta
hogy ez egy
rossz indulatú pletyka amivel
megpróbálják őt lejáratni most mégis
előjött megint ez a kérdés és az az
igazság hogy így laikusként így
városlakóként így kapkodja az ember a
fejét hogy akkor most kell hitel nem
kell hitel ha most tegyük fel fel is
vesszük és van is értelme akkor akkor
két év múlva megint fel kell- vegyünk
ugyanennyit és és most még a harmadik
kérdésemet is felteszem és aztán engedem
hogy hogy kimond ezt a a témakört hogy
vállalkozóként tudom hogy a hitel és
hitel között különbség van tehát amikor
egy üzleti terv alapján valaki felvesz
egy hitelt és meg tudja indokolni az
valójában egy eszköz amivel a a a
vállalkozását tudja virágoztatni viszont
van az a fajta hitel is ami amikor az
alkoholista apa elissza a jövőhi pénzt
és és egyszerűen nincs ki pénz kenyérre
és akkor fel kell venni gyorsan valami
nagyon rossz hitelt azért hogy hogy
éljen a család na most melyik
kategóriába tartozik a kettő közül az a
hitel amit most tervezünk felvenni
mennyi hitelre lesz még szükségünk
és és akkor mennyi az annyi tehát miért
kell ennyi hitelt
felvegyünk nagyon pontosan leírtad
egyébként a a helyzetképet mert hogy én
magam is így voltam ezzel tehát
amikor nekem ez volt az egyik legfőbb
dilemmám amikor el kellett dönteni
hogy belevágjak ebbe az egész történetbe
vagy nem hogy azt hallottam az
önkormányzati képviselőtől azt hallottam
belső információkból is a hivatal ból
hogy óriási hiteleket kell felvegyen a
város mert nagyon rossz gazdálkodás
zajlott és nagyon rossz
pályázatok hívottak r amikre nem
feltétlenül volt túljelentkezés mertogy
mások látták azt hogy ezeknek lesznek
hátulütői és aztán azt mondtam hogy
ennek ellenére is valaki most el kell
vállalja ezt a ezt a nehéz szerepet
láttam benne kihívást és igent mondtam
és így valahogy miután megnyertük én is
megnyugodtam és azt mondtam hogy hát
mert hogy arról szólt minden hogy
egyébként nincsen adósága a városnak
nincsenek kifizetetlen számlák még úgy
vettem át gyakorlatilag elődömtől hogy
volt egy ilyen adásvétel gyakorlatilag
ahol szintén elmondta hogy egyébként itt
nincsen adósság nincsen hitel nem kell
felvenni semmiféle kölcsönt minden
rendben van pénzügyi szempontból és hát
aztán eltelt kettő hét még a még az első
héten sem idegeskedtem és a második
héten már jöttek a kollégák hogy na
akkor megérkeztek a számlák több
forrásból jönnek gyakorlatilag a
problémák tehát hogy voltak számlák
amiket visszatartottak hogy majd egy
kicsit később állítsanak ki de a
munkálatok el voltak végezve
gyakorlatilag gondolok itt nagy
mobilitási projektekre igaz azért a
betlennegyedben a tábornegyedben is
komoly aszfaltozási munkálatok zajlottak
a vár esetében szintén csak
november-decemberben állítottak ki két
nagyértékű számlát ugyanez volt a tompa
iskola esetében illetve a minifocipálya
esetében is és voltak olyan
csapdahelyzetek amikor túl sok pénzt
kértünk gyurafehérvárról bizonyos
projektekre nem költöttük el mert hát
ott nem tudtuk elkölteni és ők is kértek
vissza pénzt mert azt mondták hogy hát
nem költöttétek el adjátok de az a pénz
nekünk nem volt meg mi feléltük
gyakorlatilag
és és volt egy harmadik olyan rész
amikor és ezeknek ennek pont a múlt
héten jött meg az eredménye amikor
szándékosan nem fizettünk ki bizonyos
vállalkozókat vagy azt mondtuk hogy mi a
számlákat nem igazítjuk ki hiába kötelez
bennünket a törvény különféle
bíróságokra mutogattuk arbitrázsra
vittük ezeket az ügyeket és nyilván
ezeket papírforma szerint elvesztettük
és akkor most jelentkeznek azok a
szolgáltatók akiknek még szintén van
1eg-2ét millió lejes kifizetetlen
számláj
számlaakiigazítás címszó alatt és itt
már van egy végleges döntése a
választott bíróságnak hogy igen valóban
mi ezt ki kell fizessük nekik és még
negyedik olyan dolog ami azért
jelentősen meg fogja terhelni a városi
kasszát azok a perek perekket már
vesztettünk el még fogunk elveszíteni
ahogy én átlátom ezeket a jogi
helyzeteket és és itt nem kis összegű
büntetőkamatok illetve késedelmi
kamatokról lesz szó
visszatérve arra valóban vállalkozásnál
van jó hitel és rossz hitel én azt
gondolom hogy mi most papírforma szerint
jó hitelt vennénk fel merthogy arra vesz
arra is vehet csak fel a város egyébként
ami e-us pályázat tehát ahol valaminek
az önrészét kell álljuk most
vitatkozhatunk azon hogy ezek milyen
intenzitású eu e-us pályázatok hogy
mennyire kellenek azon még inkább de
tény és való hogy a projekteknek hogy
ezeknek a projek projekteknek egy
bizonyos részét az európai unió állja és
mi mellétesszük a a saját önrészünköt
így van a legnagyobb probléma viszont
nem az mi erre vesszük fel papírformán a
a hitelt de mi ezt egyébként megbírnánk
saját pénzből is hogyha nem lennének
ilyen buta ügyeink amiket ki kell
fizetni mint elmaradt számlák mint perek
mint mint ezek a hiúsági kérdések amikor
csak azért is azt mondtuk hogy úgy
bocsátunk el kollégát hogy tudtuk hogy a
megalapozó akta nem feltétlenül jó
tudtuk hogy nem
feltétlenül törvényes amit csinálunk és
a nap végén azt mondtuk hogy úgy se mi
fizetjük meg az árát ez közpénz majd
megfizeti a város és sajnos ilyenekből
hát most láthattuk hogy pénteken jött ki
az alapfokú ítélet csak az egyik esetben
a személynyilvántartó iroda
igazgatójának 50000-re és erkölcsi
kártérítést ígért meg tehát a fizetését
fél évre amíg nem volt a pozíciójában
azt már
visszafizettük és még ezen felül kapott
50000 lejes erkölcsi káltérítést és még
elindított egy pert ott első fokon 20000
let kapott ezek nekünk nagyon sokba
kerülnek vagy vannak még ilyen kollégánk
a kollégáink a puskásatiet például ott
egy évnek a fizetését adtuk meg majdnem
és ezek mind ilyen
hiúsági kérdések voltak vagy egyszerűen
ilyen valahogy valami rosszat láttunk
olyan ügyekben amik nem feltétlenül
léteztek a bíróság szerint hm ez ugye az
érzésed alapján ez így hány millió lej
az a
rosszféle tehát a hitelnek az a része
ami ilyen hiúsági ügyekre fog elmenni a
hitelt nem vehetjük arra fel tehát a
hitelt arra vesszük fel minden esetben
hogy pályázatok önrészét finanszírozzuk
amit megtehetnénk egyébként saját kören
kségvetésből is nem olyan rossz
egyébként a sajátnak a költség a
városnak a saját költségvetése hogy ne
tudnánk bizonyos önrészeket fizetni
tehát hogy mi azért azt szögezzük le már
az elején a vállalkozóknak köszönhetően
annak köszönhetően hogy a a lakosság nem
fogyott akkora mértékben mint esetleg
más
[Zene]
településeknél nem rendelkezünk nagyon
rossz
költségvetéssel de ezek az adóságok
amiket hozunk azt eredményezik hogy
muszáj hitelt felvegyünk hitelt
felveszünk tehát arra hogy
finanszírozzuk a pályázatokat a saját
költségvetést pedig nem tudjuk erre
fordítani hanem arra fordítjuk hogy
ezeket a lyukakat betömködjük igen tehát
hogy hogy hogy rosszul tettem fel a
kérdést a szavaknak nagyon fontos
értelmük van a saját
költségvetésből érzés alapján hány
millió lei megy el hiúsági kérdésekre
itt most vízválasztó az lesz hogy milyen
ítélet születik a szejkeperben a sjkeper
fről azt kell tudni hogy ott egy olyan
szerződés köttetett amiben azt írtuk
hogy a büntetőkat az
0,1%-a a szerződés összeértékének öt éve
húzódik a szejkei per naponta így van
naponta és jelen pillanatban hát jelen
pillanatban a múlt héten kijött egy
független igazságügyi szakértői vélemény
amiben azt mondja hogy ott nem volt
semmiféle probléma és látnivaló azt ki
kellett volna fizetni sőt még azt is
mond hogyha az utólag elvégzett
munkálatokat is kifizetjük akkor
szerinte kettős finanszírozás gyanúja is
léphet fel más kérdés hogy egyébként ez
senki nem kérdezte a a független
szakértőtől ő valamiért mégis fontosnak
találta azt hogy ezt
leírja a papírra úgyhogy itt most egy
nehéz helyzet van nyilván a városnak is
védekeznie kell ez egy érdekes sztori
egyébként ez külön megérne egy kérdésst
talán és akkor itt most érinteném is
hogy én is azt gondol
vagy én is azt gondoltam
amíg nem voltam benne ebbe a helyzetbe
hogy hogy igazságtalan ami történik a
vállalkozói világgal szemben hogy
pereket indítunk hogy hogy megpróbáljuk
vagy vagy hogy el akarunk
lehetetleníteni vagy kitalálunk olyan
helyzeteket amik miatt szerintünk nem
törvényes ez a szerződés most én vagyok
a másik pozícióban amikor is meg kell
védenem a a várost tehát nyilván én
nekem is azt kell csináljam hogy noha
van egy véleményem én köteles vagyok
védekezni úgyhogy most védekezni fogunk
megpróbálunk mi is felhozni okokat azért
hogy miért láthatta a város úgy hogy
hogy ott valamiféle törvénytelenség van
és utána pedig a bíróságra vagyunk bízva
tehát amit a bíró dönt az fog
megtörténni de számodra ez az egész
szejke így most már tiszta mert nekem
olyan kusza és homályos az egész nem
tudom dönteni hogy ott mi történt és
gyanitom hogy a 90 pár sz a
városlakóknak nem érti de még én sem
látom teljesen tsztáyet tát nem merném
azt mondom hogy 90%-ig ismerem de még
mindig van olyan 10% amitől meg tudna
inogni egyik vagy másik irányba a
véleményem mai nap elvállalnád-e a
polgármesteri pozíciót a mostani
jelenlegi tudásoddal nagyon nehéz kérdés
nem tudnék erre válaszolni igazából
azért nem tudnék válaszolni mert
én megszoktam azt hogy az
intézkedéseknek gyorsan van látszata és
jól érzékelhetőek és ez nem az a műfaj
[Zene]
sokkal több segítségre van szükségünk
minden barátunktól legyen ez budapest
bukarest megyei tanács brüsszel mind
amit eddig gondoltunk és én erre
megpróbáltam már őket felkészíteni
folyamatosan beszélünk arról hogy ez a
város azért nagyobb bajban van mindt
amit mi az előszobából láttunk tehát
most bejutottunk a terembe megismertük
volt már időnk arra hogy megismerjük a
helyzetet itt hogy valóban szintet
tudjunk
lépni koncentrált és nagy arányú
segítség kell mindenkitől akinek fontot
székelyudvarhely én azt mondanám
hogy a mostani tudásommal a mostani
helyzetismerettel
hát sokkal nehezebben mondanék igent
mint tettem azt ezelőtt egy évvel mert
hogy kábé ezelőtt egy évvel született
meg a döntés hogy igen
nekivágok ez egy pofonok sorozata volt
akkor az elmúlt pár hónap amikor még még
számít a szepofonokra hogy ilyen rejtett
csontvázak jönnek elő a a szekrényből
igen de szerintem most már tisztában
vagyok azzal hogy honnan számíthatok
ezekre a okra most jött egy pár olyan is
az elmúlt időszakban amire egyáltalán
nem voltam felkészülve érzelileg amúgy
hogy viseled ezt mondtad hogy tudom hogy
te is egy alapjába véve egy konfliktus
kerülő személy vagy
és dolgozol ezen ezeket hogy viseled
ezeket a pofonokat ez nem az a műfaj
ahol nagyon sokáig menne a konfliktus
kerül és azt látom szóval már vannak
konfliktusok amiket fel kellett vállalni
és most jönnek sorjában amikor például a
költségvetésről van szó
és tudatosítani kell intézményvezetőkbe
tudatosítani kell olyan jellegű
kedvezményezettekkel mint a
sportegyesületek képviselői mint a
különféle rendezvényszervezők a
kulturális egyesületek a civil
szervezetek képviselő hogy nincs pénz
mindenhol egy kicsit visszább kell venni
tehát nem ebben az évben kell valami
óriási nagyot álmodni mert nem bírja meg
a költségvetés és a közös teherviselést
ilyen szempontból nagyon fontosnak látom
tehát meg kell értenie a zt a helyi
rendőrség vezetőjének de a
színházigazgatónak is de az
iskolaigazgatónak is hogy egész
egyszerűen anyagilag nem fogjuk bírni
ebben az évben azt hogy nagyobb álmokat
valósítsunk meg tehát most tényleg össze
kell húzni egy kicsit a nagrág
sziat nem voltam erre én sem felkészítve
vagy felkészülve és nem nem szeretem nem
ismerem ezt a műfajt amikor amikor rossz
híreket kell közölni emberek kell de
most már kezdek belejönnié kezdélzjönni
igen amúgy megértőek-e a vezetők ha
őszinte vagy akkor igen tehát hogyha
elmondod neki hogy egész egyszerűen
nincs pénz és nem azt mondod hogy lehet
két hónap múlva lesz hanem azt mondod
egész évben nem lesz akkor megérti
duzzok de megérti és ezt a taktikát
próbáljuk vagy ezt a stratégiát ha úgy
tetszik alkalmazni a városlakókkal is
egyszerűen ha azt látjuk hogy valamelyik
utcának nincsen pénze az aszfaltozására
azt mondjuk hogy nem fog erre sor
kerülni tát akkor ezt nyíltan elmondod a
a azoknak a személyeknek a város nincs
amit tegyek mert hogy én egy
eléggé szociális ember vagyok sokat
járok ki mindenhova vannak
barátaim mindenféle rétegből velük
rengeteget kávézom kijárok
szórakozóhelyekre megiszom egy sört
elmegyek egy színházba moziba egy
kulturális előadásra és én ott nem
akarok pironkodni vagy nem akarom hogy
valaki azt mondja hogy hát de nekem te
azt ígérted hogy jövő hónapban itt
aszfalt lesz vagy
ez nem
igen tehát akkor inkább elmondjuk hogy
ez ez ez most nem fog tudni megvalósulni
vagy ami megvalósul az nem más
mint rehabilitálás ami mindannyian
tudjuk hogy mit jelent utak esetében
tehát hogy három hónap múlva még
csúnyább lesz az egész igen azt hiszem
az emberek ilyenek hogy ha tudják mi mi
ilyenek vagyunk emberek hogy ha tudjuk
hogy értelmes szenvedés előttünk akkor
tudjuk vállalni akkor akkor be tudjuk
fogadni úgymond de hogy ha ha kapunk egy
ígéretet és akkor abba csalódunk és és
értelmetlennek tűnik ez az egész akkor
nagyon-nagyon fel tud háborodni mindenki
úgyhogy tényleg talán a legtisztább az
ahogy te is csinálod hogy az emberek
között jársz elmondod nekik nem
köntörfalazol vagy hogy elmondod
mennyibe kerül nekik tehát vannak
rengeteg ilyen kérdés van miért nincs
villamos hálózat miért nincs ivóvíz
miért nem megy fel a különféle dombos
vidékekre rejtőutca széldombzóna az
ivóvíz megcsináljuk ezt várospénzből és
elmondod hogy nem ezt ezt ha azt akarod
hogy hát fél év múlva ivóvized legyen és
az kellő nyomással jöjjön abba bele kell
pótolj üüm sőt abba azt te kell meg te
kell kifizesd egész egyszerűen a
szolgáltatónak mert a város nem tud
ilyen jellegű költségeket
felvállalni vagy és igen a legtöbb
probléma egyébként
abból jön amivel találkoztam hogy valaki
ígért valakinek valamit az az illető már
nincs itt mert hát milyen a közféra
jönnek mennek az emberek és akkor jön
szerencsétlen ember és azt mondja hogy
de hát ezt nekem megígérték 12 éve hogy
ne csak az elődömre menjek vissza hanem
ő neekki ezt megígérte a város második
polgármestere és azóta húzódik ez az ügy
pedig meg volt neki ígérve de van akinek
tavaly ígértek meg valamit é ilyenkor
felveszed a a válladra és elmondod hogy
ezt bár megígérte valaki most én vagyok
a polgármester és én mondom neked hogy
ez nem fog megtörténni igen ez ez ez ez
elég konfliktusos egy helyzet ez még
mindig könnyebb helyzet mint és ilyen is
van és ilyen szempontból is van igazuk
embereknek tehát könnyebb erre nemet
mondani és azt mondani hogy te ezt nem
tudod felvállalni és nem is teigg érted
mint amikor jönnek az emberek te egy
kezdő
politikus vagy vagy és nyilván a
kampányba a kampány ígérgetésekről szól
és jön az ember és azt mondja hogy ti
megígértétek nekem hogy erre sor fog
kerülni a következő mandátumban és igaza
van tehát hogy ő ha kell le tudja
játszani nem kell lejtszani mert pont
pontosan emlékszem hogy melyik lakossági
fórumon mit ígértünk és komolyan is
vesszük ezeket az ígéreteket tehát be
kell tartani de az embernek csak el kell
mondani hogy oké négy hónap telt el meg
fogjuk valósítani de hogy a harmadik
évben
és már ez látom hogy hogy egy kicsit
olyan indulatossá teszi hát nyilván
mindenki visszafogja magát de de a
legtöbb esetben azért türelemre kell
intsük az embereket és elmondani hogy
nem ez az év lesz az ahol a legtöbbet
meg tudunk valósítani abból amit
ígértünk tehát hogy most is nekünk van
egy 100 pontos listánk mint nagyon jól
tudjuk hogy hogy sokat vállaltunk és
most is vannak pontok amiket már meg
tudunk oldani és amiket amiket meg
tudunk valósítani ebben az évben de a
java az az az még hátra les hogy látod
az a vállalt
ígéretek között a mandátum végéig hány
százaléal lesz
meg nem mernek ilyen százalé-os
becslésekbe vonatkozni két fő célom van
amit szeretném hogyha ebben a
mandátumban maximálisan tudnánk
teljesíteni az egyik a terelőút e ez
tényleg nagyon fontos a város
szempontjából ott kaptam például egy
váratlan pofont ugyanis tudni kell azt
hogy bármely város tererőutat vagy
gyorsforgalmi utat vagy bármilyen más
ilyen nagyobb beavatkozást szeretne
ahhoz van egy mesterterv ami 10 évente
készül az országban és abban benne kell
legyen na már most itt a mesterterv
romániának 2021-ben készült és ha valaki
letölti vagy ránéz akkor egy szó nincs
odor hészek hogy ez körül semmilyen
szempontból sem gyors forgalmi út sem
terelő út sehol mestertervet nem
csinálják újra csak
2031-ben szóval itt egy nagyon komoly
politikai lobbi tevékenység kell ahhoz
hogy az udvarhelyi terelőút valóban
megkössük a protokollt az országos
útügyi társasággal mi már a kezdési
parancsot kiadtuk tehát hogy a tervezési
fázis elindult mi azt vállaltuk hogy az
első mandátumban nyomvonalat is mondunk
megmondjuk hogy konkrétan hol fog
elmenni és megszerezzük a pénzt is erre
és második mandátumban megvalósítjuk ezt
nagyon szeretném és az uszoda kérdése a
másik igaz két nagy projekt ünk van
letéve az országos befektetési
társasághoz az egyik az uszóa a másik
pedig a sportbázisnak a kérdése mind a
kettő túlmé túlméretezett és
fenntarthatatlan bizonyos szempontból
tehát hogy udvarhelynek ez régi baja
hogy egész egyszerűen ő nem akartuk soha
és ez egy pozitívngatív tehát mindennel
együtt jár mi nem akartuk soha elfogadni
a készt tehát az országos befektetési
társaságnál tudni kell azt hogy típus
projektek vannak egyes kettes hogy van
egy harmadik vonal hogyha valaki magának
valami sokkal nagyobbat kigondol azt
megtervezteti bizonyos szabályok alapján
területet biztosít neki és a többi és a
többi akkor szintén felkerül a listára
csak ott már különféle más és sokkal
nagyobb lobbi tevékenységen keresztül
lehet finanszírozást találni na most mi
egyeskettes típusút bármikor tudnánk
uszodára de mi készítettünk egy sajátot
így van egy óriási beruház egy egyébként
szép minőségi fenntarthatatlan lesz
tehát hogy nagyon sok pénzt kell majd
rááldozni de hogyha ez van akkor ezt
kell bevinni ezt is beszéltük antal
orantátoralú hogy hogy egy harmadik
típusú ez teljesen önkormányzati
képviselők döntése volt én úgy tudom
udvarhelyen és ez pont az elmúlt négy
vagy nyolc évben folyamatosan a
tervezésen vitáztak hogyha jól tudom ott
belső körökben hogy az egyes ami a
legnagyobb az azért még túl kicsi a
városnak s hogy azért mégsem legyen
az hanem a nálunk fontos a az úszósport
legyen egy nagyobb és akkor lett egy
igazán nagy ami még egyszer mondom
fenntarthatatlan de ha ez van és arra
van terület akkor én azt kértem most
voltunk antalorán szenátorral egy
hónapja a vezetőségnél az országos
befektetési társaságnál hogy valahogy
ezt próbáljuk meg bevinni és ennek
sikerülnie kell szintén az első tehát
azt szeretném hogy az első mandátum
végén a azúzoda hát az legalább ott
legyen a az átadás állapotában hogyha
még nincs is átadva de lássuk hogy igen
ott lesz egy úszoda tehát ne azt mondjuk
hogy megint csak tervek vannak vagy most
már bekerült ott a listán minden ott van
a listán amit kell és bevisznek azt ők
felteszik a listára azt is mondta
mosolyogva az igazgatónő hogy hát a
semmi hogyha ott van a listán tudja hány
soros az excelünk az 45000
ott van a listán igen hát ezen sok
kacagtam én is hogy úy hogy ez egy ilyen
pszichológiai trükk amivel lehet az
embereket manipulálni amikor azt mondjuk
hogy a papírok már el vannak indítva
vagy a tervek már megvannak
olyan mintogyha azt mondanánk hogy már
már csak meg kell csinálni igen de de
valójában a terv és a megvalósítás
között akkora különbség van nem tudom
hogyha most 100 pontot le kéne osszak
akkor 5öt a 95-höz vagy egy a 99-hez
vagy 1000 a vagyis hogy
9999 az egyhez hát ugyanakkor tervek
nélkül nem semmi esélyed nincsen
finanszírozást találni nilván nyilván
tehát először a tervek kellenek nyilván
de hogy hogy azt sugalni az embereknek
hogy a megvalósítás az már csak a csak
az van hátra ez ez bizonyos szempontból
manipuláció
úgyhogy úgyhogy akkor ezt a három
projektet emelnéd ki az uszodát a
sportkomplexumot és a nem a
sportkomplexumot nem a sportkomplexumról
arról teljesen le fogunk mondani tehát
az az a
tényleg teljes egészében
fenntarthatatlan tehát hogy hogy az egy
ilyen nagy városoknak is komoly kihívást
jelentené ott szeretnénk egy kisebb
projektet megpályázni egy típus
projektet az országos befektetési
társaságnál és én nagyon remélem hogy jó
eséllyel az meg fog tudni valósulni ez a
nagy projekt ami rengeteg pénzért készül
ez
szerintem nem fog támogatásra találni so
sajnos ha most így a következő négy évet
nézed akkor milyen címkét aggatnál az
évekre mert így ahogy most értettem a
2025-ös év ez a húzzuk meg a nadrágszat
év mi lenne a 2026-os évnek a a
cíkéje 2025-ben már úgy kell tudatosan
építkeznünk hogy ezt 2026 és 2027-ben
láthassuk hogy ennek a gyümölcse
megjelenik és van jó pár olyan projekt
ami ilyen szempontból meg fog tudni
valósulni ma is zajlik például a
lakossági vállalkozói illetve civil
szervezetekkel konzultáció a
központi zonális rendezési tervről ez
igaz gyakorlatilag udvarhely történelmi
központjának a keretrendszerét fogja
szabályozni hogyan lehet majd építkezni
hova lehet majd behajtani de egészen
azon át hogy milyen színnel lehet
kivakolni a központi részeket udvarhely
központjába ez gyakorlatilag a malom
utcától a villanyteleputcáig tart és
ennek nagyon szeretném hogyha egy olyan
tudatos építkezés lenne az eredmény hogy
2028-ban valóban a város központi
arcolata már másképp nézne ki hogyha
lenne nekünk is egy terünk amit szívesen
használnak a lakók amit belaknak
tulajdonképpen én igaz most egy olyan
irodába dolgozhatom hogy az ablakon
kinézek pont a a központra nézek pont
orbán balázs szobrára nézek és látom
hogy mennyire kihasználatlan a park jó
most nyilván tél volt meg előtte ősz
volt most fogok kapni egy másik képet
egy egy tavaszi vagy nyári időszakról is
de azt gondolom hogy ott például ráférne
egy kis átalakítás hogyha már ott
átalakítunk valamit akkor mindenhol azt
látom hogy az emberek már szívesebben
ülnek ki teraszokra jobban érzik magukat
hogyha a gyermekek is egy kicsit úgy
tudnak játszani futkorászni hogy hogy
valahol ne legyen forgalom én nagyon
szeretném hogyha ilyen irányba
indulnának el ezek a folyamatok és
például teresíteni lehetne azt a részt
sőt a városháza előtti részt is
egy kicsit nyilván figyelembe véve azt
hogy ott azért üzletek vannak ott
panziótulajdonosok vannak tehát őnekik
bejárásokat kell biztosítani de egy
kicsit jobban átadnánk a közösségnek de
ugyanakkor figyelnünk kell a parkolásra
és a parkolókérdés az az az mindig
aktuális nálunk nincs elég parkolóhely
úgyhogy ez minden minden kicsit minden
mindennel összefügg de ilyen szempontból
szeretném hogyha haladni tudnánk úgyhogy
most
2025-ben nagyon sok területen olyan
alapot kell letegyünk amire 26-27-ben
úgy építkezünk hogy 28-ban ennek
eredményei legyenek miért legyenek
eredményei hát van egy nagyon banális
válasz egyrészt azért mert választások
vannak és ez nekünk is politikailag
fontos de másrészt azért mert tényleg
azt látom hogy a legtöbb ilyen
projektnek két-három év a kifutási ideje
mi is annyi időt eltöltünk
engedélyeztetéssel
műemlékvédelmi jóváhagyásokkal és a
többi és a többi hogyha valaminek nem
most indítunk nem most indulunk neki
akkor akkor annak nem fog meglátszódni
az eredménye a következő egy-két évben
és és még egyszer mondom én egy olyan
közegből jövök ahol azért jól látható
eredményei voltak a következetes
munkának és és ezt szeretném itt is
apropó parkolás egy gyors kérdés én
többször hallottam felmerülni ezt a
parkolóház kérdését hogy legyen
parkolóház ne legyen most éppen hol
állunk a tervek akarunk-e parkolóházat
udvarhelyen szerintem akarnánk
parkolóházat udvarhelyen az a az egyik
legnagyobb probléma és az egyik
legnagyobb kérdés hogy ezt közpénzből
meg lehet-e oldani azért azt látjuk hogy
közpénzből nem nagyon létesültek
parkolóházak sehol máshol tehát
kolozsváron is igaz jól tudjuk hogy
például a református egyház adott át
református katolikus nem is tudom a
házsongrádi temető mellett egy egy új
parkolóházat
de nem feltétlenül tehát hogy amíg
nincsenek erre uniós pályázati forrás
addig addig nem tűnik életszerűnek az
hogy közpénzből tudjunk parkolóházakat
építeni egy együttműködés egy ilyen ppp
tehát egy public partner egy public
privát partnerkedés az az
kivitelezhetőnek tűnik ahol a város
gyakorlatilag adja a területet és a
befektetőtől azt várja hogy a a
parkolóházat építse fel ő pedig nyilván
azt fogja várni a maga oldaláról hogy ez
a beruházás neki térüljön meg ez
elképzelhető ilyen irányban már
beszélgettünk is befektetőkkel akik
gondolkoztak szeredában
sepsőszentgyörgyön és hasonló
projektekkel ott sem sikerült még
nekivágni tehát nem olyan egyszerű ez a
dolog de de közpénzből ezt én úgy látom
hogy nem fogjuk tudni megoldani parkolók
kialakításában a negyedekben ezzel
fogunk foglalkozni a betlen negyedi a
közművek melletti területhez hasonlóan
beazonosítunk ilyen területeket máshol
is és hát ne legyünk naívak eu
pénzek erre nem lesznek mert nem erre
hajaz az e-s vagy nem errefele halad az
eu-us politika hogy könnyítsük meg az
autósok dolgát mindenhol azt látjuk hogy
egy
kicsit arra nevelik az embereket hogy
jobban vegyék igénybe a tömegközlekedést
kevesebb
károsanyagkibocsátású járművel
közlekedjenek szóval ez egy nehéz kérdés
lesz és az nagyon nagy probléma lenne
hogyha tovább növekedne a személyautók
száma a városban és akkor visszatér érve
a terelőúthoz mert úgy érzem hogy ez az
akilesina itt a a az udvarhelyi
közlekedésnek
hogy van esély hogy ezt a 2031-es
mestertervet megelőzzük és igen van
nagyon erős lobbevékenysége a mestertven
kívül is kaptak finanszírozást
elkerülő útvonalakra és mi távlatokba de
realistán kell gondolkozzunk tehát
látnunk kell azt hogy hamarosan az
autópálya elfogja érni a szovátai részt
ha autópálya lesz szovátán akkor
valószínűleg a csíkrészről és
udvarhelyszék részről is a nagyautók a
logisztikai járművek mind udvarhelyen át
akarják megközelíteni a hozzájuk
legközelebb levő autópályát ami szovátán
van tehát mi akkor tényleg belefulladunk
a forgalomba hogyha nem lépünk igen
úgyhogy ez ebben tényleg azt gondolom
hogy a mínusz egedik idő pontban vagyunk
tehát hogyha elkészülnek a tervek a
következő évben akkor akkor az se gond
mi azt ígértük első mandátumban de
valahogy ha hamarabb tudnánk erre
finanszírozást találni az még jobb lenne
hogy lehet hogy 21-ben nem kerültünk be
nem tudom fogalmam sincs annyira
2021-ben egyáltalán nem gondoltam arra
hogy én fogok ebbe a székbe ülni és
egyáltalán az hogy létezik mesterterv
tőlem távol állnak az ilyen technikai
vagy bármilyen jellegű dokumentációk azt
most tudtam meg am
amikor amikor volt egy gyűlés sepsés
szentgyörgyon székelyföldi
polgármesterekkel és pont ez volt a
kérdés hogy akkor nézzük meg hogy mik a
prioritások a romániai magyar
közösségnek hogy milyen projekteket
vigyünk előre és akkor odakerültünk és
láttuk hogy hát udvarhelynek
szinte sehol nincsen szerepe a
mesterterben egyáltalán nem szerepel és
nyilván most beazonosítottunk új
lehetőségeket de nagyon korlátozottak a
a lehetőségeink és ez egy nagyon
igazságtalan dolog mert hát nem csak a
szlogenünkből derül ki hogy székelyföld
szíve székelyudvarhely de hát ha
székelyföldben gondolkodunk valóban a
szíve udvarhely tehát ha megnézzük hogy
milyen úton lehet eljutni most szováta
fele például mennyire
zsúfolt mennyire forgalmas mennyire
nincsenek ilyen legalább a kalonda tető
fele a a felfele tartó részen két sávó
útszakaszok nagyon igazságtalan és akkor
megnézhetjük azt is hogy másik felén
csíkszereda fele is elképesztően
forgalmasak az útszakaszok székelyföldöt
fejleszteni nem lehet anélkül hogy
udvarhely székinrastruktúráják ne
vonnánk bele és ne gondolnánk át
komolyan hát olyan turisztikai nagy
turisztikai potenciállal bíró
települések kerülnek nagyon nehéz
helyzetbe mint parajd vagy koronda
rengeteg a turista nem jó az áthaladó
forgalom ilyen szempontból ezeknek a
településeknek sem tehát nagyon újra
kell gondolni ez így van így ahogy
mesélsz ezekről valóban rengeteget
tanulhattál most az elmúlt hónapokban
rengeteg új terület van ilyenkor egy
csapat körb vesz téged és kiegészít
téged vagy ezeket tényleg most hogyha
tegyü felmész bukarestbe ezt úgy
képzeljem el hogy te és a szenátor úr
leültök és és magadra vagy a saját
tudásodra vagy bízva vagy pedig tényleg
egy csapat van körülötted is tudsz
konzultálni jogászokkal és és más
szakemberekkel is te igazából a az
akaratot képviseled
nem a a a technikai tudást nagy bizalmam
van egyébként az emberekre az emberekbe
úgy általában illetve a csapattal is aki
körbevesz tehát például alpolgármester
úrhoz tartozik a műszaki osztálya a
szociális lakásoknak a kérdése
és még van egy-két terület de egyáltalán
nem szoktam belefolyni az ő munkájába
tehát azt látom hogy szépítgeti toldozza
foldozza várost azt tudom hogy
rengeteget dolgozik azt látom hogy
rengeteg szociális lakásigénylő van
megpróbálja ezt a lehető
legigazságosabban kiosztani most éppen a
kritériumrendszereket rakják össze hogy
megint újabb pár 10 lakást szét lehessen
osztani a blcseszk illetve a cekend
utcákba bejáratokba nem folyok bele az ő
munkájába mert maximálisan megbízom
illetve ilyen jellegű bizottságok
alakultak rmds-en belül is min a
sportbizottság az egyik legnehezebb
feladat egy egyébként mert óriási anyagi
ráfordítást teszünk a város
költségvetéséből a sportra és ezt
valahogy keretezni szabályozni vagy
stratégiára alapozni kell tehát van egy
jó sportbizottságunk ők fogják meghozni
a döntést arra vonatkozóan is hogy
melyik sportegyesület idén mennyi pénzt
kapjon nekem egy kérésem azért volt én
nagyon örülnék hogyha a
szabadidőportágak ha a tömegsportok
gyakorlatilag egy kicsit több pénzt
kapnának mert meggyőződésem hogy a város
büdzséjéből egy színvonalas futóverseny
például ami megmozgat több 100 embert
megszervezére legalább annyira fontos
mint fenntartani a professzionális
csapatainkat tehát oda szeretném hogyha
valamivel több pénz jutna még ebben az
időszakban is de ugyanilyen jellegű
bizottságaink vannak akiknek
gyakorlatilag a döntést a kezükbe tettem
például a helyi rendőrséget felügyelő
vagy szabályozó bizottság azért hoztam
létre mert azt szeretném hogyha
megismernénk azt hogy milyen mi miért
alakultak ki ezek a problémák vagy miért
ilyen sok a panasz a helyi rendőrséggel
szemben és ők tudták a munkát beletenni
tehát ők meghallgattak egyenként egy
órát talán minden egyes helyi rendőrt és
most hallgatják a panaszosokat és
március 31-én le fognak tenni egy
javaslatot amit én el fogok fogadni mert
ezt a témát ők ismerik a legjobban és
megvan a bizalmam bennük úgyhogy nem ez
nem egy one man show és nem is lehet one
man show tehát hogy ezt ez ez ide sok
embernek az alázatos munkája kell mert
másképp csak ilyen tessék látsék
intézkedést lehet hozni vagy egy olyan
döntést ami hasraütésszerűen születik
adott esetben vagy van nagyon sok olyan
van tudod hogyha nem járod körbe a témát
vannak olyan emberek
akik félelmet vagy bizalmatlanságot
kívánnak elültetni a fejedbe valamilyen
üggyel kapcsolatban és hogyha te nyitott
vagy ezekre a a forgatókönyvekre hogy
téged megvezetnek hogy valaki a
háttérben lopcsal hazudik akkor rengeteg
idő elmegy arra hogy te nyomozásba kezdj
úgymond ilyen ezeket hogy szűret poáró
úgyhogy erre is akkor megkérem a
kollégákat hármat négyet akik az illető
területen jók ügyesek és van idejük hogy
akkor járják körbe ezt a témát és
mondják el hogy szerintük ott mi van nem
szoktam ilyen egyből forró fejjel
döntésekbe belemenni
nagyon jó munkatársak vannak a
kabinetben is úgyhogy vannak emberek
akikre akikre számíthatok és akik nem
restek a munkát beletenni
igen hát így
ahogy meséled tényleg van egy kialakuló
csapat aki egyre bővül és az egyik
számomra nagyon fontos kérdés ez ez
ismersz máry jó pár év óta
szervezetfejlesztéssel is foglalkozok és
az egyik dolog amit megtanul tam az az
hogy ha van egy személy amelyik toxikus
egy csapatba valójában egy személy is
vagy egy szűk szűk kisebbség képes egy
egész csapatot eltéríteni hogy mennyire
fontos megtalálni azokat a személyeket
akik nem illenek bele abba a csapatba és
bár fájdalmas de ezeket eltávolítani
és tudnék itt most mesélni nagyon sok
példát így az elmúlt években hogy miket
tapasztaltam nagyon fájdalmas számomra
mert én is egy konfliktus kerülő személy
vagyok nagyon fájdalmas példák de
amikor meghallottam először a a talán a
sztá rádióban beszéltél erről hogy
amikor még még novemberben még nem
vetted át a a a a városvezetős
városvezetői pozíciódat akkor azt
mondtad ott hogy egy audittal szeretnél
indítani most elteltte jó pár hónap
és hol tartunk most ezzel az audittal
hát ez az audit az amivel a az egyik
legnagyobb késésben vagyunk meg lehet
ezt magyarázni ilyen-olyan okokkal és
ezeknek egy jó része azért racionális
hát volt egy olyan időszak amikor a
választásokra is kellett fókuszálni volt
egy olyan időszak amikor tényleg nagyon
sok időmet elvitte az hogy én magam
megismerjem a kollégákat hogy
egyáltalán kicsit berendeződjek a
hivatalba hogy hogy tudjam hogy mikor
tartok ilyen-olyan gyűlést tudom tudjam
hogy milyen ritmussal tervezem a az
ottlétemet meg és azt követően pedig hát
már decemberben megszületett ez a
megszorító intézkedés és a
salátaatörvény a trénulé és az meg
nagyon megnehezítette ezt a fajta munkát
zajlik egyfajta átv átvilágítás inkább
azt mondanám hogy ne féljenek az
audittól a hivatalban ettől függetlenül
is tehát hogy rengeteg kolléga jön el és
mondja azt hogy ő mit lát az elmúlt
egy-két évben a fiatalabbak vagy az
újabbak vagy a nagyon régiek és az ő
tapasztalatuk ilyen szempont ból talán
még fontosabb akik évtizedek óta itt
vannak azok elmondják hogy hogyan
váltakoztak a helyzetek az erőviszonyok
az emberek milyen furcsa történéseket
tapasztaltak a az elmúlt időszakban és
abból is már leszűrünk egy bizonyos
képet nem könnyű egyébként ez az
önkormányzati audit szóval nagyon sokáig
nem találtunk csapatot sem rá és
és azt kell látni hogy nem is egy nagyon
hálás feladat illetve ami a legrosszabb
és a vállalati audittól a leginkább eltő
hogy az intéz vagy eltér az az hogy az
intézkedéseket azt nem tudod a
gyakorlatban azonnal a hatályba lépni
mert egyszerűen mások a szabályok más a
törvény elít nem lehet eltávolítani csak
úgy egy személyt hogy akkor azt hogy
holnaptól negyedre vagy két hónap múlva
negyedre az sem és akkor mi a terv hát
azt hogy még várom a a visszajelzéseket
még mindig folyamatosan vannak azért
programálva a kollégák akik egy-egy
történetről mesélnek vagy egy-egy
egy-egy folyamatot mutatnak be és így
ahogy már a beszélgetés elején
említettem itt március végén áprilisban
egy konkrét átalakítási tervvel fogunk
jelentkezni az illetékeseknél ezeket már
részben összehangoljuk a törvényekkel is
de nyilván kell egy nagyobb
közigazgatási rálátás hogy meddig lehet
feszegetni a törvényi határokat mert
hogyha most szóról szóra bet tartjuk a
törvényt és nem nézzük egy kicsit a
kiskaput akkor most szinte lehetetlen
lenne alkalmazni hivatalba vagy tehát
hogy felesleges elküldeni embereket mert
a helyükre nem alkalmazhatsz nyilván a
most üres pozíciókat amik ilyen egyedi
posztok azokat be lehet tölteni de
nagyon óvatosan kell döntéseket hozni
mert adott esetben oda is kerülhetünk
hogy egy-egy embert valahogy elküldünk
de nem tudunk újat hozni de most nyilván
hogyha egy nagyon toxikus embert küldünk
el akkor az ő nemléte az már egy
pozitívum szóval ez nem feltétlenül
lenne probléma
igen
amikor tehát az első az előző ciklusban
elég sok mindent láttam és volt pár
nagyon vérlázító történet amit amire
most így emlékszem és nyilván nem az én
tisztem ezeket
felhozni viszont amikor ezt az audit
ötletét feldobtad akkor akkor nagyon
fellelkesedtem mert valahogy úgy voltam
vele hogy ezek most akkor a felszínre
fognak kerülni mert ezek olyan dolgok
amik abszolút meg mérgezik egy
cégkultúrát vagy akár egy akármilyen
szervezeti kultúrát
az emberek sokszor úgy tesznek mintogyha
ez oké elfelejtettük már rég történt de
valójában ez nem felejtődik el valójában
azok a sebek ott vannak és és és ezek
fertőzött sebek úgyhogy már akkor
emlékszem még nyáron volt erről írtam
egy cikket pontosabban ezt megelőzte az
hogy elkezdtem felhívni pár embert aki
tudtam hogy érintettek ebbe az ügybe és
mondtam hogy rendben amikor amikor
elindul az egész új átveszed a hatalmat
akkor menjenek és keressenek meg téged
és a a lelkesedésem letörött őszintén
szóva egy pár nap és pár hét után mert
az emberek elkezdték eleinte kedvesen
visszajelezni hogy hát úgy se számít a
mi véleményünk meg úgyis csak jön az
egyik polgármester és akkor te te csak
az egyik vagy ők már sokat láttak és mit
számít az én történetem és soha nem
változik úgy se semmi de ott rejtetten
azért ott volt mögötte hogy amúgy benned
se bízunk ühüm honnan lehet érthető pers
tudni hogy
te a te szavadra lehet adni és akkor
gondolkoztam azon hogy ez így nem jó ez
így nem jó mert valójában így nem fog
változni semmi ha egyszerűen a a a
személyes bátorság az a fajta kiállás
hiányzik hogy hogy felálljanak és és
elmondják azt amit amit kell haj
valójában ahhoz hogy egyáltalán
történeteket kapj és a történetekkel
majd együtt kezd majd valamit ha ez
hiányzik akkor egyszerűen nem fog
változás történni úgyhogy már már akkor
megírtam egy újságcikket ami ami most
fog megjelenni két nap múlva ennek
örömére hogy hogy hogy tudom hogy hogy
foglalkozol ezzel a kérdéssel és
szeretném bátorítani itt is a
podcast hallgatóit hogy ha valamit
tudtok akkor beszéljetek egyszerűen
azért mert a közösségünk akkor tud
fennmadni akkor tud úgymond a hajónk
biztonságosan úszni tovább hogyha az
emberek akik fel kell szólaljanak fel is
szólalnak hogy engedelmesk yünk a
lelkiismeretünknek a aki arra hív
esetleg hogy szólaljunk fel na most én
nagyon remélem hogy te ilyen
történeteket fogsz kapni mert egyszerűen
hogyha te egy új csapatot akarsz ebből
összerakni áprilissal vagy akár március
vége április elejével kezdve ahhoz ahhoz
tényleg ezeket a mélymélysebeket fel
kell valahonnan tárni gyanítom azért te
is tudsz már pár ilyen történetet csak
nincs mondjam úgy hogy hivatalos
bizonyítékod rá ezekre van van egy pár
történet amivel szembesítettek a
kollégák és én nekik is elmondtam azt
hogy mi ezt én ezt nem fogom a szőnyeg
alá söpörni tehát nem az van hogy ők
most ezt elmondták kedvesen
meghallgattam és nem fog ennek
következménye lenni hanem azt szeretném
hogy
hogy ezt valóban így ahogy mondtad
merjék felvállalni hogyha esetleg többen
tudnak ilyen történetekről akkor mondják
el és akkor ennek jól látható intézkedés
lesz a vége na nagyon sokan gondolkodnak
úgyis igazuk van hogyha megnézzük
gyakorlatilag politikusok jönnek mennek
ez a polgármester most van négy év múlva
lekerül a polcról jön egy másik én most
miért ártsam magam ilyen ügyekben de
hogyha igazán zavarja őket hogyha és és
ez fontos tehát hogy egy ember átlag
nyolc órát tölt el a munkahelyen tényleg
a második otthon de van akinek a legfőbb
otthonja nekem van olyan kollégá ak
tudom így van de nekem vannak kollégáim
akikről tudom hogy 10-1 rát ben sajnos
nagyon kevesen de vannak
[Zene]
hadd érezze már jól magát tehát őt ha
igazán zavarja akkor nem tök mindegy
hogy ki a polgármester valószínű nem
vele kapcsolatosak ezek a történetek az
viszont fontos hogy a munkahelyen jól
érezze magát komfortosan jó kollégákkal
legyenek körbevéve jó hangulat legyen
bizalmi légkör legyen egy bizalmi légkör
akkor jobban tud haladni mindenki akkor
talán egy kicsit hamarabb meri aláírni
azt a papírt és azért mind en papír
gyakorlatilag ami hozzám kerül még öt
ember által alá kell legyen írva minha
már köztük van egy nagyfajta
bizalmatlanság vagy hogyha közöttük van
egy olyan kapcsolat ami valamikor
valamiért megtört akkor akkor nem fog
működni és ez kihatással van az egész
hivatalnak a működésére napvégén
kihatással van a
kampányígéreteinkre az eredményeire a
városnak és a város életére úgy
egészévben szóval ezeket rendezni kell
azt gondolom és én ráadásul nem is
vagyok egy olyan
vezető vagy adott esetben polgármester
most aki
akiek ne lehetne elmondani ezeket a
dolgokat úgy kerültem be mer nyilván én
is egy olyan ember vagyok hogy én amikor
megérkeztem nagyon kevés volt de öt
embert biztosan fel tudtam volna sorolni
akivel nem akarok abban a helyzetben
ahogy én odakerültem együtt dolgozni
mert azt mondtam hogy ő elfogult ő nem
meg eléggés szakmai ő nem tölt elég időt
a munkával és azt hallottam hogy nagyon
sokat mással foglalkozik és pont az
ötből három ember egyébként az elmúlt
négy hónapban meggyőzőtt arról hogy ő
profi
ő félre tudta tenni a második
munkahelyét hogyha úgy tetszik és már
csak a hivatalra koncertát mindenki
megkapja a második eséét tényleg
és én szeretem azokat a vezetőket akik
nekem adott esetben ellenmernek mondani
és e ezt jól meg tudják indokolni és
elfogadom tehát hogy azért most is
szoktunk bemen belemenni vitákba hogy
vannak olyan kérdések amiket szeretnék
én gyorsabban megoldani vagy esetleg úgy
hogy a törvényesség határát súrolja és
figyelmeztetnek a a vezetők hogy oké de
ez nem jó mert ők láttak egy ilyen
példát egy olyan példát és én ezt el
szoktam tudni fogadni tehát ellent lehet
nekem mondani nincsen oribálása az
irodában legfennebb néha egy kicsit így
durcizunk egymásra de ez nem igazán
látható másoknak hanem mi tudjuk hogy
van egy ilyen egy ilyen kis belső vitánk
belső feszültségünk és ezek egy idő után
elhalnak úgyhogy tényleg várom hogyha
még vannak ilyen történetek és valaki
nem jutott el hozzá tehát ez most már
akkor így örülök hogy így megfogalmaztad
hogyha valaki azt a kérdést teszi fel
magába hogy mit számít az én kicsi
történetem valójában ezt mondtad hogy az
ilyen kicsi történetek el kell jussanak
hozzád mert ezekből rakódik a kicsit
történet hegyeket tud mozgatni hogyha úg
hegyeket tud mozgatni és mit mondanál
viszont annak a személynek aki azt
mondja hogy én félek a nevemet
felvállalni én én az anonim szeretnék
maradni és félek attól hogy tegyük fel
az pont a fölöttesemről tudni akarok
valamit mondani és hogy hogy hogy mi van
hogyha megtudja hogy hogy én beszéltem a
polgármester úrral ühüm nyilvá hogyha a
helyzet é ezt súlyozni szoktam tehát
hogyha
egy olyan jellegű dolog van hogy most
most tényleg nem akarok bármilyen példát
mondani de hogyha valakibe csak az zavar
hogy
egyébként a kávécsőszéét én kell
elmosogassam mindig vagy soha nem hoz
magával kenyeret és mindig megeszi az
enyémet akkor azt vállaljuk fel együtt
ha úgy tetszik vállald fel te é mondd el
neki de ha nem akkor üljünk le hármas
elmondom én és akkor legyetek ott
mindketten de ha súlyos ügről van szó
ami tényleg egy komolyabb kihágás és
akkora súlya van hogy úgy érzem hogy ez
anonim
is fontos ügy és vállalható akkor akkor
ott nem kell nevet vállalni de akkor
hozunk mi így intézkedéseket és elmondom
annak a csapatnak aki esetleeg segít
nekem abban hogy átszervezések legyenek
vagy vagy hasonló dolgok hogy én kaptam
egy ilyen visszajelzést azt vegyük
komolyan nem mondom meg nektek sem hogy
ki az de de megbízható az információ és
és bizonyítékokkal szolgált hogy
keressenek meg téged ó hát ezt a kor
legg tudják hiszen elmondtam elég sok
esetben hogy aki még azt sem szeretné
hogy a kabinetten vagy titkárságon
keresztül jöjjön be hozzám írjon egy
privát üzenetet írjon a közösségi
oldalamon azt is én
kezelem csak én fogom meglátni és akkor
összeülünk egy kávézóba összeülünk egy
olyan helyen ami adott esetben nem a
hivatalban a munkaidőn túl is úgyhogy
bárhol meg lehet keresni és nyilván a
városlakóknak is a rendelkezésére állok
őket azért szeretném hogyha ilyen a
fogadóórában tudnánk tartani nagyon sok
fogadóóra van tehát nem az van hogy
két-három havonta találkozunk egy-egy
három percet a
városlakókkal hanem két hetente azért
ttházas fogadóóráim vannak ilyenkor egy
napot is rászentelek hogyha arról van
szó ennek az ügynek és tényleg nagyon
sokan jelentkeznek nagyon sok a probléma
a városban ennek megfelelően és ehhez
arányosítva nagyon sokat nem is tudunk
nagyon rövid idő alatt megoldani de de
egyiket sem felejtjük el és mindegyiknél
vállalunk egyfajta határidőt vagy azt
mondjuk férfiasan becsületesen hogyha
nem tudjuk megoldani hogy hogy hát ez
egy következő mandátumra fog maradni
értjük nagy probléma tudjuk hogy az
lakhatásukat az élhetőségüket egyáltalán
a város élhetőségét nagyba befolyásolja
de akkora beruházás hogy ennek nem
látjuk a helyét a következő egy-két
évben lezárva az audit
témát akkor két-három hét múlva tehát
hogy most így ahogy nézem így a az
március 31-én egy készen kell legyen az
hogy kábé hogyan akarjuk átszervezni a
hivatalt ezt előbb első körben majd
bemutatom az osztályvezetőknek
igazgatóknak és április végén pedig jól
érzékelhető eredményekkel legyenek tehát
hogyha valakin úgy érzi hogy olyan
jellegű információi vannak vagy olyan
jellegű kérései vannak ami a hivatal
működését alapvetően befolyásolja
egy-egy ember megítélését ö
befolyásolni tudja azt megkérem hogy a
következő egy-két hétben azért jelezze
abszolút és még azt tenném hozzá hogy
ezen sokat gondolkoztam hogy mi a
különbség a besúás és a a között hogy
megkeresnek téged hogy elmondják és
valójában ez ez ez nem besugás ez
valójában az van hogy a az udvarhely
jövőjéről szól tehát ezeket a
vállalásokat nem fogod tudni egy csapat
nélkül elvégezni és hogyha nincs egy
koherens csapat amelyik megbízik
egymásban mer például ha alacsony a
bizalom akkor senki nem fog rizikót
vállalni és ha nem vállalnak rizikót
akkor minden lassú lesz minden drága
lesz minden minden ezerszer meg kell
majd drágni mindenről majd gyűlést kell
tartani és egyszerűen a komplex dolgok
nem fognak megvalósulni itt udvarhelyen
úgyhogy í úgyhogy ez a tétje igen ez ez
az egyik legnagyobb rákfenéje szerintem
a hivatali működésnek hogy talán nem
kellően nagy a izalom az osztályok
között sem és tehát nincsen olyan
nyilván ez nem is az a műfaj ahol
becsukott szemmel meg tudok bízni
bárkivel mert hogy itt és ez a
legnagyobb különbség
a én nem szoktam soha egyébként védeni a
feltétlenül a kollégáimat hogyha nem
muszáj vagy úgy egyáltalán a
közért dolgozó embereket de itt azért
tényleg minden egyes aláírásnak súlya
van és hogyha valaki hibázik és ezt
megállapítja a számvevőszék akkor a
legelső aláíróig vissza lehet menni még
azért
magánvállalatoknál javarészt hogyha
valaki hibádzik a legalsó szinten őket
nem szokta érni következményit valóban
érheti éppen ezért is nagyon fontos a
büzalmi légkör nagyon nehéz kialakítani
és nagyon törékeny
és
és és valóban ez egy kardinális
kérdés zárásként le van egy pár rövid
kérdésem köszönöm szépen hogy az
auditról beszéltünk én nagyon kíváncsi
vagyok és várom majd amúgy hogy mi fog
mi fog ezzel majd lenni utolsó
kérdésként így záró kérdésként hogy
látod mi a legnagyobb kihívás most
székely udvarhely előtt nem kellenek
közösségbontó tevékenységek bizalmi kört
kell építeni a hivatalban de bizalmi
kört kell építeni a városban is
tehát hogy kicsit mindannyian dolgozzunk
azért politikai színezettől
hogyha úgy tetszik elvektől függetlenül
hogy ez a közösség előrébb tudjon menni
és fel tudjunk zárkózni mert bizony
lemaradásban vagyunk és bizony nem
feltétlenül jók az előjelek sem hogy
hogyan tudunk vagy milyen anyagi
lehetőségeink vannak ezeket a ezt az űrt
egy kicsit
kitölteni nem lesz ez egy könnyű időszak
de meggyőződésem hogy tudatos
építkezéssel egy bizalmi kör
kialakításával a közösségnek a a
rendbetételével és összetoldásával
foltás
összehozásával amivel egyébként
próbálkozunk tehát most már volt egy
olyan eseményünk ahol több 100
vállalkozó jött el ahol egymással egy
kicsit tudtak beszélgetni miután az
lejárt célirányosan bizonyos rétegeket
megpróbálunk majd összehozni de nagyon
fontos hogy udvarhelybe tudjunk egy
kicsit mindannyian gondolkodni és
tekintsünk el különféle
érdekektől köszönöm szépen szinusz hogy
itt voltál köszönöm én is a lehetőséget
és akkor beszéljünk egy pár év múlva
újra lehet hogy még hamarabb lássuk hogy
hogy haladunk ebbe a legen így legyen
így az úton köszönöm szépen a
lehetőséget ha tetszett ez a műsor akkor
iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel
tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre